ce bâtiment de 18 mille mètres carrés
s'appelle native un projet de démolition
reconstruction place choiseul à montigny
le bretonneux opérationnel en 2021 avec
un bail déjà signé avec l'entreprise
orange l'opération est menée par le
groupe codic promoteurs immobiliers
présents sur le territoire depuis 2000
vraiment saint quentin est un très bel
cour de récréation pour nous c'est une
ville qui a été construite très
rapidement dans les années 60 70
donc il ya pas mal de bâti à reconvertir
et que ce que nous pouvons offrir à
saint quentin c'est de venir avec des
architectes de renom
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ses prix de 5
millions de m² d'immobilier d'entreprise
2018 une année record avec 222 1500
mètres carrés de transactions et un taux
de vacance de 5 5% et une
complémentarité avec les autres
territoires de paris saclay on a ce
travail avec eux de mise en connexion de
tout le pôle économique de saint quentin
en yvelines avec les forces académique
de recherche sur l'ensemble de paris
sacré car il s'est classé 3 pôles un
pôle culturel à versailles un pôle
économique donc à saint quentin et un
pôle scientifique à saclay donc les
trois poules trail en sont la preuve
bon et on est également dans le même
conseil d'administration qui s'appelle
le pea paris saclay en jouant
régulièrement le simi l'occasion aussi
de nouer de nouvelles relations c'est le
cas avec cicas hospitality exploitant
hôtelier présent en angleterre et aux
pays bas
il ya énormément d'entreprises c'est
quelque chose de sain territoire
dynamique qui est et reste une zone
d'attrait pour beaucoup de clients
corporate et donc de fait peuvent
générer des nuitées pour nos hôtels sur
saint quentin en yvelines 250 mille
mètres carrés de projets d'immobilier
d'entreprise sont en cours de
développement